il ya deux sortes de personnes pas par
tous ceux qui ont envie d'autres et ceux
qui n'ont pas sali à 10 ans austin
désolé ça va j'ai un filtre pour sérieux
il faut un pilote pour avoir une vie
sociale et oui y est ça en fait je ne
veux pas que tu sois dépendantes un
gadget
[Musique]
simon aprilia
bonjour part mais je suis ton meilleur
ami prêtes à l'emploi
permettons bbox est trop bizarre je suis
le pilote de barney tu viens dans ma
cabane secrète pour le light est
amoureux il ya plein de petites notes
qui sont aussi tout savoir sur moi
cheveux bruns taille un médecin quand un
mètre 80 serait mieux les filles se
moquerait pas de toi
fabriquée pour te faire des amis
demandes d'amis demandes d'amis il que
sa paire salle ces genres il sert
carrément
démontre la tâche peut pas lutter monter
la tête pour être embêté d'accord je
peux pas lui démonter la terre où je
suis pas méga sécurisé et tout et tout
copilot trouvent les crêtes
je vais me pencher là dessus tu crois
tu vas pas rester ici ils vont envoyer
au bois hier on va au broyeur en sang
non le broyage sans rien d'amusant
[Musique]
pas amusant
et qu'il trouvait le rebelle on a besoin
de personnes doutent j'ai un ami
aujourd'hui c'est aussi triste que
pathétique ou
[Musique]
pas de problème
atari
c'est mon grand alors ce people bon
allez vous deux les quatre mains en
évidence
je sais pas et un l'oeil puis moi même